more than ever we need philosophy today
even the most speculative in the sense
of reflecting on on itself science has
to rely on a set of automatic pursue
positions like a scientist simply
presupposes in his or her very approach
to nature a set of a set of implications
of how the nature functions what's the
causality in nature and so on and so on
and philosophy teaches us that
philosophy teaches us what we have to
know without knowing it in order to
function
even in science the silent
presuppositions I claim that what is
happening in for example in quantum
physics in the last hundreds of years
this things which are so daring
incredible that we cannot we cannot
include them into our common sense view
of reality that Hegel's philosophy with
all its dialectical paradoxes can be of
some help here I claim that reading
quantum physics through Hegel and
vice-versa is very productive what I
really want to do is rehabilitate
classical philosophy today
that is to say Hegel was a child of his
time we are 200 years later how to
repeat Hegel not to do the same things
as he did but repeat in new
circumstances the same gesture and even
here more for Hegel than for Marx I
think we should even return from Marx
back to Hegel so this is the focus of my
work then come come all the things for
which I am unfortunately better known
for example my dealings with critique of
capitalism analysis of popular culture
and so on and so on but friendly to use
the not very appropriate metaphor known
for from today's military adventures all
these my writings and politics on
analysis of Hollywood and so on is more
or less collateral damage of my basic
work I think this is also what
to be done today I think the danger
today is precisely a kind of a blend
pragmatic activism you know like when
people tell you oh my god children in
Africa are starving and you have time
for your stupid philosophical debates
let's do something I always hear in this
skull there are people starving there
let's do something I always discern in
this a more ominous injunction do it and
don't think too much
today when it